so i have to start today with
potentially
just a major major scandal and um
the scandal is the growing possibility
that the trump administration
is now lying about coronavirus case
numbers and this is extraordinarily
serious
if true this is potentially
the trump administration doing what
trump attacked
china for doing which china pretty
clearly did do
this this does not mean china didn't do
it this would mean that china did it and
now potentially the united states
is doing it so the number of cases
appears to have flattened in the united
states
since the exact day on which hospitals
were told don't send your data to the
cdc anymore
send it to donald trump's uh alex azar
who runs health and human services and
on the day that this happened this
happened july 15th
16th i said we now have to look
skeptically at a decline or leveling off
in cases
because now the reporting is going to
the politicized department of health and
human services instead of the cdc
and even more stunningly as i will show
you in a moment
a complete reversal in case trends took
place
in the states that trump won in 2016
exactly on the day that this change
in reporting took place so there's an
excellent video on youtube about this
by a guy named jeff hester who goes into
a lot more detail than i will today i'm
going to talk more about the political
implications but we're linking to jeff's
video in the description for this
youtube video
so you can see him lay it out but the
gist of what's going on
is that on july 16 the first day
during which data was no longer sent
from hospitals to the cdc but instead
to the department of health and human
services cases nationally started to
flatten
immediately now without looking into
this in more detail
maybe it was a coincidence maybe
something was done
policy wise maybe there's another
reasonable
explanation as to why cases seem to have
been
on an aggressive upslope up until this
day
and then right when the reporting change
happens
the cases level off but what jeff hester
then does
is brilliant jeff separates cases and
states won by
trump in 2016 and cases in states won by
hillary clinton in 2016 and when you do
that
what you see is stunning cases
nationally had been trickling up since
mid-june
now it had been a slight uptick in the
hillary states
and a massive growth rate in the red
states about
three times the growth rate in red
states than blue states you had
starting in mid to late june up until
july 16.
on july 16 nothing changes
in the case growth rate in blue states
just that continued
trickle and in red states case growth
actually goes negative forget about
slowing growth
they start to see declines in new cases
in trump states i i need people to
really understand this
on exactly the day that the cdc stops
receiving data from hospitals and
instead data goes to hhs and then comes
out from there
hhs run by trump tool alex azar
you have a reduction in the number of
new cases
in the trump states this is a completely
believable slope for blue states just
everything stays roughly the same slow
growth
and it is a completely unbelievable
change in slope in the red states given
what we know
we know that it takes eight to ten weeks
to flatten the curve
before you start seeing a decrease in
cases
what you see as social distancing and
mass squaring and shutdowns
work you see the growth rate start to
slow down and that takes four to six
weeks eventually you hit a peak
and then you see the decline start so
in this case we see just a straight up
reduction in new
cases in red states so there's the
speculative part but i don't i don't
want to get to the speculative part
quite yet
first let's just focus on what we know
and let's try to find other explanations
see what other explanations we can come
up with
we have cases on a trajectory leading
into july 16
very very large growth we have no real
policy change on july 16th in any case
it takes a couple weeks to see policy
changes
there were no real policy changes around
july 1st
and then on the day that the one thing
that does change
is that data goes from hospitals to hhs
instead of hospitals to cdc
we see that the numbers dramatically
improve
in the red states red state cases start
to decline while there is no change
to the growth rate in blue states what
explanations could there be
other than corruption and lying in the
red states exactly as we predicted this
would leave itself open to
when we announced this policy change
weeks ago well maybe
the red states are being more cautious
but that's not true
red states are being less cautious when
it comes to social distancing policies
and masks and so on and so forth
and again that change would have had to
happen weeks before
to see the effects starting on july 16th
we can get into speculation about
the weather or humidity but these things
have been widely debunked and they
really don't explain the data anyway
and then you realize and then again this
is still just fact for now
they lie all the time that's just a fact
they lie about crowd sizes
they lie about hurricane maps trump
modifies them with a sharpie
we have the most and best testing 15
cases will soon go to zero not
necessarily a lie but completely
untrustworthy
so we have to consider that this is
corruption and these are fake numbers
and it looks like we may well be lied to
well you could say david you know it's
weird because
even if hhs is doctoring the data the
cdc is reporting the same numbers
as the h as hhs is the cdc also lying
well
as far as we now know cdc is getting
their data from hhs in other words yes
cdc and johns hopkins they're all
reporting the same numbers
because the numbers are now going
hospital to hhs
hhs does whatever and then spits the
data back out which is the data that
everybody else uses so that doesn't
really prove anything or serve as a
defense
so i don't have anything more for you
today in the sense that
we need to figure out what's going on
here it is
not plausible that you would see a
reduction in new cases this
quickly in red states given what we know
about policy given what we know about
lag times and
hopefully if there are state-level
whistleblowers that will be able to shed
light into this
we will hear from them soon and indeed
we must call out the corruption and it
exists but understand that
if they're lying about cases they're
going to have to lie about deaths at
some point
because we know that case spikes lead to
death spikes
and if you lie about only the cases all
of a sudden
your death rate relative to cases is
going to go way up so
if they're lying about cases at some
point they're going to have to lie about
deaths
just not testing doesn't make this go
away not reporting deaths
certainly doesn't make it go away but
for a desperate cornered president
who sees himself as potentially losing
to joe biden
i would put nothing past him to try to
win this election
given that we've caught him lying what
20
000 lies and misstatements per the
washington post
extremely disturbing and exactly as we
worried would happen
when this policy change took place if
you are
anything like me you probably aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called steady md
they're one of our sponsors you take a
quiz you get matched with a licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one hour
video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steadymd
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free
quiz see which doctor is right for you i
took their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment
to get started just click the link right
underneath this video